um so
i think like would you say like you kind
of originally came onto the scene in
terms of people knowing who you are
outside of your city or your friend's
circle due to the soft white belly uh
videos yeah software underbelly yeah
underbelly shout out mark later that
that's more ladies i loved your guys's
interview when you had them on your show
too that [ __ ] was done yeah that one
that one right there uh
that one touched me man because it was
really like a
you know just a revolving door was a
full circle moment you know what i'm
saying to sit there with him it actually
like made me feel a certain kind of way
because i'm like damn you know i'm i'm
here you know and me doing what i did
with him made me
step my game up some and like i said bro
i never expected none of that [ __ ] man i
just i got into it i got a chance at it
and i don't like to uh disappoint myself
anything that i've ever done i like to
be great at and i ain't done a lot i'm
saying but whatever i did do i made sure
i was great at and i made sure i was
great to me um you know so i did the i
did the interview with him like when i
went on there bro i promise you man i
didn't even expect it like the comments
was bad you know i didn't really i'm
like man i'm not used to that i'm from
the street anybody got something to say
to you they gonna say it to your face
you know so it's different when you see
a bunch of trolls or a bunch of people
sitting there making all these these
comments you know i'm saying that you
don't even really know who it is
motherfucker's like man lock him up why
is this type of person outside i'm like
whoa
what the [ __ ] right i'm just telling you
i'm saying my password things
are telling my story but man people get
so [ __ ] captivated and wrapped up and
like
they they feel like their way
should be is the right like you're
saying that that's what should happen to
you or this is where you should be you
say because you do something that ain't
you know
it's not valued to society but [ __ ] what
is
what really is man i mean [ __ ] who they
call me the kick i'm saying the kettle
black like ooh
also like i don't think people
understand like the culture of las vegas
to be 100 honest like at the end of the
day like if you're from vegas like it's
not crazy to think that like you know
pimps exist and they're normal people i
know that's crazy let me tell you
something it's not just vegas it's
anywhere it's anywhere but specifically
like like it's like vegas is like it's
like a part of the culture there like
they just say that because it comes with
a lot of gambling drinking and
prostitution so you would think that it
it resonates with that and it does but
that shit's been going on everywhere
chicago bay i mean whatever city you're
in yeah
the longest so i can't sit there and
just pinpoint vegas and say oh yeah you
know that's the
the mecca of it because it's not it's
man that shit's all over it's it's it's
got its pieces everywhere to me
you know what i'm saying because when i
was moving i seen it everywhere it
wasn't just my city that's why
[ __ ] got to really get out of
their backyard
you know i got out of the backyard so i
got to see okay they moving like this
over here you know they were first time
any sort of interaction with pimps in
vegas there's a place next to little
darlings that i don't know if it's there
anymore it used to be called kelly's
casino kelly's you know kelly's i was
there for many years yo kelly's i was
there they tore down they ain't there no
more this is a wild place they're not
there no more i've seen a lot of crazy
[ __ ]
i remember because my homie one of my
best friends was nancy working when you
were up in there older white lady
probably so
one of my best friends
so one of my one of my close homies at
the radio station was my boy ron dizzle
and ron was not 21. so the only place i
could take them was [ __ ] little
darlings and we were [ __ ] with a
couple of [ __ ] and little darlings
so i used to be they'd let them in
kelly's casino though yeah so we used to
just go get [ __ ] face to kelly's casino
with a bunch of pimps and hoes and then
[ __ ] walk over walk across the
parking lot and go to the [ __ ] middle
it was it was definitely uh a cool like
waiting place you had to stand in that
square and get buzzed into the bar yeah
it was it was a cool place like you know
what i'm saying to like pass time in
between time while you're waiting to
make a move or waiting to do something
but that [ __ ] got bad after a while like
people were starting to get beat up
every night
like [ __ ] police up there a lot
now because [ __ ] be tripping in
the parking lot i got it got real ugly
yeah harry for sure he got ugly after a
while bro i watched all that [ __ ]